[Music]
I'll see chris hemsworth met Spanish
actress Elsa Pataky on a blind date an
accent coach set them up I left her a
voicemail said hello my name's Chris
would you like to go on a date as you do
and Justin Timberlake and Jessica Biel
met at the Golden Globes Walt this is a
star strong he Brown and wife Ryan met
at Stanford we were in the same dorm
freshman year she watched him audition
for a play and well that was it I was
you were 18 years old and the things
that this man could do at 18 the theater
also brought Sarah Jessica Parker and
Matthew Broderick together we met
through up at the inner company that he
was a founder of with his friend Kenny
and my brothers Meghan Trainor said yes
and is engaged to actor Daryl separa
they were fixed up by a celebrity friend
Chloe grace Moretz told me she had a
really really nice friend and I was like
that's crazy I'm looking for a really
really nice guy and he's like you guys
have to meet and we did Melissa McCarthy
met husband Ben Falcone when both were
in the LA comedy improv group The
Groundlings
Jason Bateman met Amanda his wife of 17
years at a hockey game won both just 20
he walked by with some cocky remark
nobody I was like what a sarcastic guy
never and then now look it up I bought
her a hot dog and a beer and that was it
Reese Witherspoon did not meet her agent
husband Jim Toth through work he
actually stepped in when a drunken
friend was hitting on her and this is a
photo of when Nicole Kidman met Keith
Urban for the first time at an LA event
in 2005 the craziest thing is to have a
photo of when you first met someone just
took that photo and sent it to us
I remember thinking I had such a crush
on him and he well he wasn't interested
in me that's not true it's true really
he didn't call me for four months
[Music]